EDHOSTY BIL FM AND T
ATHEER
CTDIREON OORRSLE WELHOS, W''UT O
ETHERS I A 1AS597 NA FMILHA T
TE
NSH WIT THERY STO OFLS WEL
93USMO 18 RIOAD AIOPTDAATNF O
TH HLS WGELEL NOVHE T W OARF
PANIANEDCK MYNEIS LTE WRSHO
GHTHOUT TTHAANAR MTIERS WE
INHENGDI TD NI UTEATES
THEENOC DUMRYTAHE TNSE US
NTSCIETSISDINC ILUNG SAR CLANAG
TOXP ERELO
ICMMCOUNTHE ATWILINT IELNTGE
TILIVIZA TS ONINVE UHENIE.RSCI
♪
N:SO BTHOREFE NDCYE LIEREL FL,
THEAS WER G AENSU PALER
IN
TTHATOUHRGH T ALLHEOFEE DP
SPLI NE,O FEXI EEDST BONEYD
TTE THPEACSUY RFOF O OWN
TEMINUE.PH SER
[WINBLD OW
NOWE KOW NH TTN IHE TARLY
TS AROFH  2HE0TY,NTCEURS THI
WODAS BNGCH WATSE CEDLO,LY
BYNTELESGELINCERRE GAT
HAN
N'MA
'S.
ROACSSMEN  AIMNSALHEETRE
GOS MI, NDTO OUR -IN MDS
NDMISOU TO S MIR NDREATTH AS A
OUTONDMIS HE TST BEAHEINS  T
LEJUNG, ICTELNTLE,VAS STL COO
UNAND HEMPSYATHOC,TI WEDUA GRD
TH EITTHAR WOUENH VISYE ESND A
RESUW  DLYREEITHRNS PLASTGA AIN
.US
HEO.LL
I AMON ORSS EL WLEDANAV I H
EN Q FTIUONGOTM ROANRHELS WEL,
NOEL RION,.GSWE. LL,
THE
INDISTD ISGUHEOISTJU JNND A
PR A WITASOLSHE GAT M
R
CIOF SICCEEN F
ONTI.
HE WTERO "E WAHEOFR  T
WO,"DS OH WHN ICDES WAMA
ACE
AIRTNOT NIOORUSAD R
T DCOAASSOICWHH MEYO OF OBR
Y
RE SMBMEERNYD ENMAANHO TUS
F
OUENLIR STNIS ERPAININCKG
E
STALETRES  TOVL ERNT CHEOU.RY
G.H.NCEN DOUFO MEDE G DOR IN
IBU
R LAT TEEENWH H B- -
TET BULAWHR EN HE--E  H
NODECEUNDE  MINR FODOITG UT B
WHTELAR ENE  HEDALREIZUR O
OABRWAASDCT ENFOS R NMRTTEAIT,EN
AM BWEECEOO GS.HAD ND
WAI IVFOS RG.EN
PEOSTHE HOLEOP WAM JED METH
HIWAYS AK  TNDOO TTOHEIL H
SCAPTHEANAR MTI
HAS E
IVFORG I MENE,HEANS OTERMAR TT
.
>> WGHTHE OU TTHT ATSS HIWAT I
INSTLIENHATOG  TT SW, WWERE
VESSMP IREE NAIOBLT TATHA
E
USBECAEF OROOC BK ANERDGS
DFL
RDH ASGO,ONND TDET HAMA
AI
ESIMG PRN ONSI O.US
>>WNNE O OTH OERF EOORETO T
KR
E FON MEYS M ROHIEGSHCA R
LOAND ISEDAD HAR CFOIT WH
D
TOOK T OFFNT MHEOUANNSAI,
T
HI AWIS FELD CNDHI HN REATE.OM
>> NK YEWORASTYCI W
US JT
MODE.SHLIED
EYD ANTHER WNGCOE MIR.LO CSE
>>EW NER J AY SEISRNINN FE
D
ATHEY PREROGEDCEIN.OU STH
>> IAN CIVON CCEOOFE N
GHNIASARTME ER TGFYRIIN A
SES
BLISNG SMMH UCCOIOICUNAT
I
ATH SEDCAO-LL SR,ERUPIO OIFR
SHU YOWI,CEDV AANNOTED CHGY I
SPTEOUR E.AC
ORN:SOEEO GRG W
ISD  A
ONF O AUP GROIEF  OSCSTLOIOGISNS
INMEETHEONG  TCTUB SJE O
F
EREXATRE LRISTALE.IF
E L ALTH YOPPELEL  WOUIL
BESE
N NGEI IISTHAMRO PGR
WESOORN HAESLL,  OVENEHI TE
N
ONCOMM
HEACH R HADTOSOEAN IE BEL
VN
IKHE T LISY ELEXOFNCTEE
NORTHLIF LEN  IETH
SEIVUNER
TS REHE INOUE QTHIOSTN
E
ILIVENHANN  IITABEDVE UNIERS
ASATTH HALIF LE  IOVL ER
T WHAMAAMI I INIGINGS TTHA>>
CTE THFAVEI S HAUS JTDTA STE
COER GNGENLYALNO K SWNOT THA
PEW KLENOT  THATOURE THES I
A
IOMILLR OTN HEZAVICILI
ONT,
ATHEYLLK LOOUL FABUGSLOUY
D A ALLOT ARE LERMA SRT.O  TUSYN
EEATTH S TMSOE BL,SE UFUND A
EVIMONGERIEE FOINMAR NK
DA
:ATRRORM  FROETH
ST MONUSRO
NSRTMAIASF  OHI F
OUAMS
DCBROARST,AS OLE WONEL
WISL
TAKE US FIEM ROSCCTE NCFI
O
NCSCIEEAC FA  TT,O EWW NEVIF O
ERTREXATALSTRERI LEIF
NOW
GIEMERM  FNGRO TOBPRESO T
HEPL
ETS,NTERRELSTLA
OVDISC AIEERS,DI FNDINOUS NGAB
H
RENAE TUFEF  OLIFTS IEL-  -
AE
ALREIC PTUAS, ST ANGISONHIN I
Y S ITWA S TOFHEENCICEONIC FTI
A--SCTHS E FINCIEE IOCTN
OF
ORN:SOTH IF E ERIS L
OUE T
E,THERNT INTLIELGEE, LIF HID D
EWET R VEGETIE THNOT  TONHA
II
TGHHEE  BOTTHISRWE
ANFR
?NDIELY
RSMAE S  ITHDGOR,F  OWAEO  STH
PLRI BETEA INGTSMIAM NE
E
CTEXPE TEDO HEAVAR WKELI
IOTEINNT.NS
B OINURSTADROCA,ARHE T M
AS
AWEREESAGS GRNDVESI AESUT RHL
S
UMNY A HANNG BEI, R AOUICIDUL
ONMPSUTIE N  OTHF CEFA O.IT
EYTH WPPE ERSU AEDOSLYASBAS D
WE,RE AWOOUT R T.RS
SOD ANAL UMU, CH
IEGLR.
EYTHISRA BNDDHEEA DS RTHAY
IN
R THEITEIMSLY S.ACNTLE
FOAR  AHI WLET,LET AS20US JT N I
TOFHEIO RAD TLA PY,YHEEA APPDRE
TO BTOE INLLTAY LENCVIIB
FWHAT SALINLY TPPTOEDM?HE
LLWE, H TE ERIS I WHEAYWENT
INORHE T WTH ODSF E MLHIYTCA
PRESSORONEA PRS OFETRI PNC,ON
ROUNTOM CMEORAT, IEM R HBEEMR,
A
IT, IDWRGINS N  IHILURJONA
WHHE THI T P WNGAS TOGHER
AIAGHEINN  T WOR WLD
IASN
NEBUSI, SSIBEEM REMDE WANNGRI
HROTHUGHA MANSTANTT,
DIANG
E ALONES TONIM SARQUEND A
NGTCCAHIIG SA OHTF IE LN DOG
G NNRUINTHWNDO 7 AVEE WI ATH
ECPIEF O- - -LN EAGDO
GNNRUINN  DOWENH 7TAVH  WUEIT
A
OFECPIE INEA MT OUTS I M.TH
I  ULKWAEDDWBRP OAAY POPT ASSH
WIDS OWANNLUD SDEHTCAY UG
SI MOFT  ATIANAC M
NEHI.
THAND E CENOMOS ACRMBCOS LU
LECIRCULI , COD SEEINTA SNDING
NTSIA LE19OW R, F O TRESEHO G
E
LTAIT TS,ANIR THEESOB CBL
Y,EMPT SHE TIRELTE ANGS RMHAGIN
SSSTLILETH BLYY DER EISI
S.
D ANEDLOI OKHEOR F TONSTS
THAT I TABNHITSEHONEAC MHI
D
THOR BENEFMYE YE E IS,HEAW S T
ANARSTK NTSID LEMATH, E
IS
LVEMTHSEESE THFLOCOFK
NGHURY -IR BDS AWI- TH FCK O
BNGHURYEADSIR TNGRI FROSHLE F
H
REIEA DESBOD DI
HER,TE WRTHN EIIE BODS
ERE
INEXAM IEDNABORS,ORATIEST  IWA
FO TTHD ATDY HEHAN  BEE
D
BYEA DISSERIAC BTEIN AA,GA
STWH
EIH ICTHEMSYR STWERE
EDEPPRAR,LA SINFT A
AERL
'MAN'SSEEF DENHAS DLE FAID,Y B
OMWISDUTAD H PTHPO UN TH EISAR
H
ONCOE MM
OL CD.
D ANS ATTH IY E THWAIT W
.
ITQUAE  O LOTGSTHF IN HEAV
EDPPHAENE N  ITHRLD NCEHE TN
.
,MARST THA ATLET AS ITHONS E GIN
DTHATN'I'ENHAT PP
TYN  IANYOAY W, , KNU OW
WEHA
N  BVEEENGVAINDI MS,A.
MIFHAARSN''N  BEED,VAINDET I
NLRTCEAIBEHAY S ENTINV IES
D
NOCKATT TAT, EDBU TROUGY,
TVERYHLROHOUGIESTY UD
SEOBN ATRVIOS MOFAREGAD H B
UNO
OR BNGEFOUE RRO B.CAADST
EVK  BENACN ENTH I3819, I
SEUS PEDLALEIBMA TO PL PNYEO
H
E  LATIFHAULCOD VEEVELEDOP
ONS, MARUS JT AST  ID HAON
RTEAH.
PETHINERG UGROHES TEL
PECO,
NTSCIEADTSIS HN, SEE WT?HA
LLWE,IR FST ATHNELAT KE, ATLI
OURTN OWEAH,OLAD H P
IAE
CAPS.
♪
WTHEYEERCINAD TOHAEE S T
ICE EAP CSRE GAND R
EDD
EWITHARH ACYE
LAE RGARANS EACHDGEOL CH WORIT
TH.ASSEON
S--.SOEANS
D TH MEANET VEG
IOATN?
ST LIGRAHTERESIN WEED CITEN  OTH
ANETS''E.RFSUAC
SODAL CLE TNAM HECA.LS
E THANERAMICNOST ARORCR MEPEALIV
ELRDLO BVED ESEANAR MTI
CAADLSNA HCREE BN BYTEEAD N A
NCADVAHN TEDECALOGOLIC
CIONZALITI
RSFI19 IT,N 65HEND A TN A
N
, 1969SANAEN S CBAT SEFTRA FLY
BYANAR MS  BSED NDIEK ACSC
C
EMASMEURNDTSEN A-ULO CSE
P
PHPHOGOTRA
>>HI TSS I21GIIDN
DEN RTEIC PWIRETU, LE-ADENG
PIANE,UR FSTTAICIC P
RETU.
THAUS  IBE
FUTIL.
THLLS  IFU
>>HI T NISS AANROARW MEE GLCA
I
.EW
N:ORSO TIS MWEONSIS AT GRERE
ACTSEMEVENHEOR F TTICI SENS.ST
T BUCTE THPIFESUR O MOWS ARSH
RLD OL TOF TATISODELA.ON
WA LMAS RSKES ESLIARHE T E
D
LMOREEE IKTHN? MOO
ERTH NWEE RELSCAO NA
NOS,IT CIEEAO  NAROFS
ATLTCUIVON,IO NIG SA ONSF
OPPELE A-  -OF PORPLEOE
LAN NGRI IRTE THMANIARU CSTO T
T GGSUESANE THPLET WLV EASVOGIN
ICOLGEOG
LYAL.
THREE ERWEO VOANOEPETOS  S
SET OUGA CTHS ATNRLDOU EEH ICTHW
MOSPRE, DADAT W
, ERSO
ESL NTSEIAE, LTOIFME SD
E
ENPRES IONT LYESTRN AC
ATTHE RESPMOHEASO S
ASHI TN O T
KEMAHE TOS PTYBISILIFEF  OLI
FOFATHR E  ONSF S FENCICE,TIICON
T NOXCRYVE E BINITG,
FUTOR
NTSCIETSIS, W THEXCLEHO ETEMITEN
IS ODIINNG TUTHETS FAC
TH IATS  MONE LYIEOVE. GAMTH
THRSE ESFITLY FDS BYHAEA REVDLE
N
E  SLYOM F TOFHE
TSAC.
TBUHELL A T TAM SE,
HEEX
ORATN OFAR MAND  ALL
THPLHEOTR INETANS  S THEAROL
SYASEMST WATCC AURTTY ELGEGIN
UNRWDEAYTU-  -ACETLYAL GNGTI
AYDEUNRW
' C IANF'T T  TELHARSY ANPE
I
ATHNYOU SLOCAL N  OOKUTN I
NIATTH UTHRSVEE RO SATURSDSUN U
ANAN CMA IHENEGI TSIMM IENTY
F
THIT, ORHIE STT,OFY  IIT WUTHO
RAINBEG ERTHSSMP IRE WITTHE
IDHA TTE, WTTS  ALIMS ALETO
F DEMA OETH SUFE AMSTSTTHF E SAR
EARE  MAD, HA THEILAP CABYIT
TOAR REGOTTHD E RHEART  THE
SEIVUNERPION, E  TE ECOF
IVUNASSEER HBIHE T ATYLIO LO
TH AATNOERT  PAR U TOFHEEVENIRS
AN ANDWOERT.UTBO I
THATS  I AVEA RYZIMANG AHI TNG
T
BNGS NETOIN OS''NDMILL A
KIHOOFS  THTUGSBOUTIOEL RIG
N
OSPHD ILNDHYOP AO S O
DONT''K ASMEBO AE LUTIFN.>>
ONA
,RS O
N:ORSO ITHN ETI FICARALON MANTI
ORSTTHINY  "OFWAE R HE T
,"RLWODS IUNWAT S ODRSDETOHE T
MAERNSIA WEINIG FHTTHFOG R REI
RVN OWSU
ALIV.
ERTHETPLE ANAS WNGRO GWIO SD COL
ANITHOINSPHALEAB TT TGHY HEMI
E
F SHRI IEYTH RD,AIEMNEHI W
LE
E-LALIFON CTONEFID AUC SH
PLLD WETOU FR HTIG OALRVSUIV
IN TBYRYHATOG  CSEE NGIT
,Y
VIEVOL.NG
Y EVER TVILINGNNGHI OTH EARAS H
EVVEOLDRO FMOWHE T LE, LYTH
INSIBLYMA SLLRO MIC.BE
VEGIN NMERIOUSHE , NTTHECRMIOB
WIRO GWON COLS IESOAS FT
T
THEYAPIDOM BLYECBLVIE SITOE
E.E THEY
HEOU OREN ETPLR AN, MSROICBE
VE A TPTDAEDIVSUO RVMOTHE E
O
RTDESEOFCU SM ROHE T FNZEIWO
MAHI AYALAS,NC TNDRESHE UND
ER
THEAOCN
EE DP.
OGBIOLT ISAT ARALAS BORERYTO A
DIG EROVINTIADVE
CABILINESTI IFOIF LE SRMT, THA
A W YRS A, WOVED ULHA
N
RDREGA AEDSSTAN FTA.IC
THWI C TINHE SLIOONG OTEYSMS
FAT
EAICOM RORS,AN OISE HMSAV
BEIS DD,VECOREISLO FURNGHI
WH
EERTIAD RIALD CONOUE B
EDPEEXCTSTO  TDEY ANLIVI
NH
G.IN
INTAOS HPIT TLSHA
USE
AVULTRFOLEIOT RLITE SRI,TIZAON
STVES INHAEE BN F
NDOU,
IODIRAATT ANTOLI KHEIL
OGBIOLRETSIS ANGRO GWIAN ORGMSIS
T  SINALONLUSOTIS, ANDDS ACI,
NEKAALLIS,MM AASIAON G,
IN
INBOILT G SP INGRIS,AN
IE
ITHATS TEVWEHAD YER. DAY
V TINHEOFUUACM  A SCEPA
MULAR,IF LEMS FORAVE
RIFLOUFOINSHG RRS YEAUTIT WHO
OX
ENYG.
♪
ISIESCNT S ATSREG DYTUINETH
OFNDKIS ONNV EIRNTMES TTHALD C
LECHALFEE NGLIOR FTH OMSN
ANETANS S MOD ON S TOFHEAROLPL
S.STSYEM
1IN1,97 MINERIN NE A AIVRRED
T
MAUI, RSEQO EDPP T IGONIT ORB
ANN AYST IE.WHA IL
A HIODNGOO T,AU BECN WSEHE
RRIT AEDIV,S' 'FA SUR
WS
SCOBY EDUR BALGLA OBFOUS DT .RM
D--ORT USST
TASRM SHETOBA A WD,TE AEWLEHO N
MA TEG BANOE  MAKSIT
VIEW,G OK PINUPBO A D TVEHET,USN
ERPEEDO  TUG ABE HCTIME PA
ERCRAT
ITBUT  MTO SODBOESIL A
TVE
RTMAW N IALO ONDLAS,PETHN E
AK
OVENSEMM IENPE -- AKAN OF
MEIMNSTAMOE UN.IN
STHISG NNTUINEMUTTRH THGEERD
UNE THMOINTAN  OASRSMA WDND IEET
NTGIA GAICOL VNOCA, S
ALOGOLICRS, LYMAOTAS W NE
A
PDEADAFNELAT L.R TEAL
TRSTVA SARCHET MTH OKSN ENE PLAT
ATS OWTH MS'A'ACSUS RFE
ISH
TISHIF C ANGNDG NGHAIN AON
ALLOCOSS.CA SLE
MARS INNBES GIG INTOK, LOO
ICOLGEOGTLYAL AEA LRE, STMOIK L
H
H EAE RTSSD ANLE LIKTHE
MO
D TMEN HECOEVNT IO  OENIDCE
R WAHAN BES GUN  TTOUR
IN
RISURPNGSIAY WS.
ONG ETH MOUY ANCL IDSNHE T
MAMON IAAT, HESPREMESO HAV
D FOD UNCO BTOE OSMPED
OFAN
R.WATE
CLENTH, S E-OSUP S TOFHE
FE
BHAVEUNEGO TUPUR TN GETR SAN
,I
OUNUS PS.TEATRN
OMMESO CREPAIT WHTE PATTS RNCU
INURHE T SCEFA OFWNUR O O
PLTH BETY ISMIE SSRIPPSII R.VE
LYSLOWTH, EPRNT IERNATETIO
EMD TH ONLUIA Y FL
DFL
INOWGNUON CTIOVSLOUY
TE
IAMARTNUR SOUCEFA CLD
AV HE
EDCAUSPAUC SH  AERTTNS
NDER
IOOSN.
ASERONTROMSAAR CL EON GATH REDAD
CMARSEDTAONIN L AOTE  MOR
R
THANE HAOSSUD PP.ED
THR WAE TEREGHMIT IN LKED
T
S CSSTRU AFRER PMATOSGUR DIN
ICMEE AGTISUS CH A
THS E
T,ESPRENURUT B DCYINCL
OF
RMWAN  WTHHEETHOL PAR
AP CS
ASRELESGAE SERMO  TFOVI H AEA
R
SPATMOTHREHE, R WAE TE
Y ME
ASRELEO IEDNTUD CLOSUCHLOUD
S
ULCODHT EIGTHE ANETN IAI R
OUR FOTHNDSAS,ER PPSHA
IOMILL ONSF YEA.RS
AN SIFAGS''RETEINRPTITAONS I
COIFT,EC LD COE ULVEHA
IGINED ON MSAR
VON  IFA
E
ESCYCLMAAN, D  AHAY VEPTED
OLFSE TERAR HSHTION CDISON
S
EVEYTH D,OPELEDND A IMAEENDD
Y
ONISEXT TOAR MS DAHI TS
TSOGOLISRE ATU SINDYGS A TYHE
GIBENSE TO IRCHAR DFOTLECY
RLI
BEYD ANE THPLARET E.TH
♪
BYIFLNGYIT JUP,ERNE PIO
MENFCOIRMAESD TIS THHI WIT
SPATS MOREREHE ANAOM CBI
S
WH OLIH FETEGIRINAOND AR E.THC
Y WILECOND PNEIOER
INS  IBE
GAI
PD METOPIS ASJUDR TEAN F B
Y
RNSATU, ETH-BED MMESUEARESNT
SHT  TOWHA OMOA ONRNSAF TU
NE S TLYHEEIZF  OANE THPL
ET
RCUR CS TAONINAN A
EROSTMPH
NDR,TE AISUR SPRGIN W
MT.
VIA NGKI SPAT CRCEAFNG BISEI
RED TOAND ONAR MS76N  I19,
NGRRCAYIAU AN D MATOTEALEMCHIC
LA TTORARYLESAO MP M
TIAN
OSOILRIF LS.FOE RM
THECO DISF RYVE ONESTJU O
BANIAER OS, MARAN OR ROTY HE
BOE F  OTHSYLASOR EMST, WLDOU
DIINHATECA TWHTHT E AIE OLCHOFN
OLEV -IOUTNS- C CMIOSC,LMIHECA
ANIO BL GILOCAAT I--S
OR K
YWEVER
REHE.
T  TINHASECA, THEAT CRE
N F
ALIFEE WHNYER TINHE UEVENIRS
WO
D BEORE ETHE  RULHEANTH T
EX
IOPTN.
HAIN TTAS CRE TE,HEE AY M B
R
LLINTEENTIV CIOIZILAT
BLCAPAOMOFE  CTINIMUCANGH WIT
US.
ANMP IT ACONESSEURLV
IT WH
TNTCOACF  OR OTANHEZAVICILI
,
HOW  MHTOUOM CE WHANT D
AH
CTEFE FETMIS GH BISOW N
BESCG INDIBYSEUSD USER SIO
THHERSKE T OOR WLDR.VE
THPO SISYMT UMSI A
STBOON
UNIVSITYDENC ILUSTRNOROME
CAAN SAG,HR ANTISOLOPOG
TAS
EYHLON M AGUTAE, D TNDHE
F
HATHE ARRVDOO SCHL ONIDIF VI.TY
A SOOFPRESHETER ACURA S COSE
TIENEAEDTL SR H RCFON FELI IETH
SEIVUNER
ESPROFILR SOPHRI MIPORNSOF O
M.T.AU CO-ORTHEDHE T
IR T
RISERESLOUY- PONASEDERAPN O
LESSPOIB OOD MESCOMMICATNIO
XTTHWI EESTERARRLIIATRL .FE
GEGEORAL WTHWOD N LNOE BEZERI
1  1IN97S R FOHINRKWO I
GYIOYSLO
T IW S  INOTA TOKO UT ALKBO
FELI EREEWLSHE,RE WHE AAS DEAD
A TORWO W, GOITN'A'T O
K.
C WITASRESIONDETOO
ULSPECIVATE TITBEO  W
ANH Y
STINVEFNTME OE. TIM
>> TBE NHEUMRARF OSTURINS O
GANE AXYLOAGS  ISTLYRIGENG
LAE,HE T PLIBAROBIST OTYF SAR
PVIHANGRYNELATAYS SS MSTE I
GHHI,TH WE E K INTHILOBPRABYITSO
HOATTH TNE PSELAYSRYTA SMS
MITGHCO BE LEARMPABITH R OW
STTHD E VES ARHASOOM SE
F
HOECORRVSUEYA, ER SPHEHERET I
TA SISUIR E BLFOFELI, OT NOTO
H, OTNOCOTOT O .LD
THTSE ESBIFOF  OINN ATRMIOVEHA
ROMECO FMST A PNOROMYLYMARIRI
D ANN  JWEOIIOTHWI BTSEMCHISO T
S LLTE UOUABT P THEEBAROBL
UTEVOLNIOF  ONFELI O E
THAR,
O AMINANIDACS THD E LHIE,IK W
H
VEHAEEOW N BD FON UN
IN
ITTEMEOR.ES
WE HEAV NND FOWOUSTNT IER
LR
CUMOLEOAS LEFLN NGTI I
ACSPE
EEBETWS.STN AR
ISOF YW KOUNOER MHEATORLSIA F
CAON-BIFEDAS LTOE , XI EST
WN
B TOWHEG LDUIIN OOCBLKSF OUR
ELIFEFFSTXI OLAUR O PT.
IF Y POUUTSE THEBIRO PBA
TS
TO, THGEERDS LITEAE O  TTH
S
OFCL CONIOUSNS T ST HAWE
RD
WIAN ATHS  ITINIALMI PRE
D
WWITHO CHHI NE ONONANHE T P
EL
SENPP AARSAY TLDI AEEGRD,
NDH
TH IATS AT LSTE IFMUXIST I
ERUNE IVSEND ASTT  IMU
XT
E QUITNTUNABDA.LY
T>>HEOS MT OIMISC ESSMATITE
ABE T OUTH OMBNUER
TILIVIZAERS ONTHTMIE GH B I
H
XIGAE LATH OESN RORE DEON OF
E
LLIO
ANH ICMESY  ONLINON A F
EWU
RENDDHOUSD STS S ARHACHSU
ZAVICILI
ONTIS.
>> ANDHAT MEULWOD AN A
ONIL BLI
SUS LA PCEN STJU INR OUOW
XYGALA TGHT HAMIAICOT NTN LIF
.
>>IE B IELRE TVEHES IETSOA CI
F
GHE TSE NUPROS,OTT  JUSE.ON
IF'HE TREO'S ,  OLYNEE  HWEAV
O
PEEN OF HENGDI T
E THERY MABE TDSUSHOAN,AY M ABE
NLLMIIO
.
PTHEYYBAROBLA AV HE NGLO
YSTHIORF  OAMISTH SRIEXE PE
,
FINDGEW N
NE OS.
>> IMA IF NEGI IAN AANDVDCE
ZAVICILIANONTI WD TETOTOAL TK
EY, USTH SOU WLDSE TAYHO
UYS
BMUSTE ELYREXTMEKW BAC
DSA.
IBFEASFOITILY INPIR CKUPG
TETEINRSARLL CCAMUOMNIONTIAS W
MADE IFOCAN LIIA BRAODI
SIAS- EDGN -DIRAOEN SCISTS,
ERONTROMOTANS D
RSHE.
ASIT WDAL CLEROJEPSYC CLO
.D
OMOUE TCTHWAE S  U TATHE
STAT HADHE TAP CY ILABIT
TO
SC TANHENSEA HVEGRIT WH TEA
REONLUSOTIOWND A PSI SEREN
Y
TO ATA DIS ME NCOFHUANNDDSRE
US TORHOF DSAN OYEGHLIT S.AR
ANWID TH V THESTY ERDICTIN
ILSSPOIB PY ITOF UKIICNGAP
FNGSILEERM ROTH
>>SE PURREHN TNTECISOGOLY
AB TCTDEO TEUR OLVES
IHEYWRENHI TXYGAS LA$2 OF
BI
IOLLN.
>>ST FIR, P THEBEPLEOE THINAMG
E
WIAGSSE  BLLENC IYDIREBL
AL
ENEV IBIEITHR STHEOCMI
RY
SERETHLEMBS HEBIE OCSTRY
R ESOFSOEALDWA TITESCH,
L
BENOT HALL A TE.CLT OS
BWILLE QUE ITENFFDIER, ' LR'S
T.
IFTHEAE T FOE ODA OF
MUITOMRO,  BIG MHTEER V
YDI
T ICFFULDI [TOINBLERSCNI
E]
T FIRS, AOFLLHEREL  WIL
O
T GREA OASPHESF TS EV
TUL
WTIME TCHHI IILNKHI WLE COMN
10 YRSEA OYE10R 0 S.AR
'DOI N'OWT KNEMA, YB LGEONR,N WE
MESOAT SORFAISCTORAY DI
LETEWOOPSCE SO ORKR GTHMEIN
SILLR LAWIRECQ AUINCVI EDEOFE
ETHEREL DIBEATNGEA BMI
F  OA
AGMESSE, P AEDTEROCTGEES MSA-
RAPROTESEDCT MGESA, OO IUTNT
E.SPAC
THBEIL WL ORXT ERALYNADIRI
IM
ANRTT.
DANBE MAYGEOM SE
RANEL
RAGEOGICPHMANF IORROONTI F
W
FAR IOMIST  CHAG,IN WTD  KIN AOF
AR, ERE,HEND A TIN
HIK
YTHATL WOUILAV HE,OU PNGRIN I
WE
NTMOAD DH,ECR AFE TE, CADEDE
A
DYBOTEF  OING STREINDAN
GFANMEINULUL PS.SE
U D ANYOE LLWI BLEAB TREAD
WL SEMLOFOANY D LI POTHIEPP B
--WL SLOFIANY D  BULTFLY
AE
WTHEYT L ILNOBE C
EDOD.
WTHEY AL ILBEDEI-NTCO
CABEEE USTHEI BATS NGTHESIGD
ILEMTH WHAL VE T VUGHOHTYER
FUCARED Y LLANETH BY T ESWA
TO
SIHEALGN TNGEA MNIBEIL WL
AV
BLLAE.
THBEE STHI TWE INGF STND UERDAN
ILIT WBEL  A DTICRESIP OONF HOW
ISGSIN D OSIPONGF
RE GATE
NOTECHERGYLO W TABE LEIOFAO SH
OR WWH ILDN EYH ICTHLD COU
E
D PEE EVRSERDAN MNNTAIAI
THSOME WG INOFNDTHOR AYEA BUT
FOLOA NG TE.IM
>> ENINDW A-ND E - IENULWOD
U
IA SOCANL D CLTUULRA
ISION.
WEBEAV HE ND BENOUR O  TOUNOW
IEUNCOTRANS D R IIOEGNS
OUNR
PLBUETAN, TIT WR N HIOU
LASR
EMSYSTF.TS IEL
TIFREREHE AONIL BLITHOFS  O
CITILIVIZASON WDDCHHI ASTIICONER
CAINDIHT MTEIGHEE, B TOUWEN  W
O
AR AIN LLAR GEGAICCT
ITMMCOUN
N:SON I 16,97E  WBEULWOD
E
OOMICRMSANRGISF
REFO AER ANDFT WHA TT,
WL
SBENGRCEAHIHE TNE PLA T ATSND
A
FXILAESORLUESO TINIL FL
THTTW NEPAE NSER WEAR
DISCGEROVINE -  -THIOOLEVUTOFN
EVNSUTOLIOT THA HASDDUROCE U
N
POTHD E  MIBSSLES LIILON
OF
HERIZIV CIL.IOATNS
>>IS IT CABCEONIVLET HAA
P
LWILL FD ANINF NTRO OETH
SHWA MGTINONT UMONENFID ANA REGU
WITHEN ANTDS NAAN OSEERTHWI
LOKEG INLIFE P AROLIOSSNA
FOLALLBA PLLR YEWIOM CE
OT
GH[LAUR]TE
ANNDDED MASE TO LEOUE R
ER.
BUIT  HEOP V TMUY CHET HATH
UNFSEER OMSIR CCU INCTAES
S
DEWIR TE N HATH
ODSHDY
INIMAG OIOATNSNCSCF IEIOFIE CT
R
ERITS.
'I'NVM COITCEIND S. I
AVWE HEOT N TOU FNDUIIRHE G
E
RESO GAT IMOANN Y STDE
TIVIES, OIKELI GTH TNGO
EMO
.ON
RAACSPECSFT O ANAF SAEBEE T TNDE
DLURIIN FLYERSAG UCHEOFS  TLD O
O RADIARHE"T WF THWORL,"DS
ISHE TREIF DFETWE NCBENEE
E IESCNCIED ANSCCTE NCFIDN IOAN
YEIFHE T DRENCBETWRN EEWA
AN
ACPEE.
OUR W OWNLD H TURTD NEOUO T
BENTHE T IETPLERANSIY ARVIR.TO
AWEREHE TNES VINGUT O
NERTHE,OTH  WITRAATDEH T, YSBU
WI CERASO OT N TR,NQCOUE
BU TMPSILYO L
RNEA.
WENRE A IBEAC FT
VIHANG
ELOURSR S VEFATTBEER OUT TREHE
E ANTH WAVEREV H HBAE CK
ET
N MEHO ONR OUOWNE PLA
T.
♪
CABLLLSAE TERPE ITCO]20. 21N
[CG ONTIINMERFPEORHEBYD  T
NAAPALON CG ONTIINUTSTINIT
EH
RH ICISIBPOESNS I FLEOR
TSCA
COIOPTN ENT D AC.RACUCY
VIAPNCT IC
RG.O]
♪